another four and a half million of your
fellow americans quit their jobs in
november according to the latest federal
data it is part of what's being called
the great resignation are you among
those americans if you are guess what we
are revealing the u.s news and world
report list of the best jobs for 2022
this is a first on cbs morning so here
we go coming in at number three
physicians assistant congratulations if
you already have that job number two
nurse practitioner
and
the best job in the u.s for 2022
information security analyst we're going
to find out what that is we're joined
now by antonio barbera he is a senior
editor for consumer advice at u.s news
and world report antonio good morning to
you if you ask a fifth grader what do
you want to be when you grow up they
don't say information security analyst
but that's your number one what is it
why'd you pick it it's important uh for
the fifth graders it's important for
anybody it is uh they are the
gatekeepers of our digital information
they protect companies and individuals
uh from hackers and cyber attacks
all right antonio so why do nurse
practitioners and physician assistants
rank at numbers two and three
respectively
so health care jobs always do extremely
well in our rankings and these are two
positions that have low unemployment
rates
excellent growth opportunities
a strong median salaries of over one
hundred thousand dollars per year and
they have lower barriers to entry than
some other health care jobs they don't
require medical school
so you can start working much earlier
and you won't be saddled with hundreds
of thousands of dollars of potential
student debt
maybe that explains why four out of the
top ten jobs are in health care you know
we've been hearing from frontline
workers how burned out they're feeling
how overwhelmed they're feeling but yet
you're you're saying it's still a very
appealing job
it doesn't go away uh they the scores
for these positions do not do very well
in stress level in work life balance but
they just dominate in terms of the low
unemployment rates extremely strong
salaries and
just excellent expectations of job
growth over the next 10 years
so antonio what kind of things do you
look for when you're putting the list
together because we all made note that
nobody tv news anchors are not on your
list of the top one although although
actor is number seven actors bartenders
actuary yeah top 100 yeah
yeah journalists you can imagine the the
stress levels and the work life balance
for that and unemployment rate so some
work some work to be done there uh
yet but overall for the methodology we
look at what we think job seekers look
for most in in a new job and that's
median salary that's unemployment rate
uh that's the stress level work-life
balance as i just mentioned and whether
or not the job is going to grow over the
next 10 years so we take all of these
characteristics uh weigh them to give us
a score between one and ten and then
give it a corresponding ranking
all right antonio so i'm pretty sure we
have some viewers at uh that are at home
maybe uh some friends or family members
they're sitting back saying i'm looking
to switch careers but i don't want to go
back to school for a long time i don't
want to sit and do a whole bunch of new
training so what type of jobs on the
list would you recommend and i want to
make some money yeah money
well
look you mentioned at the top there's
four and a half million uh resignations
happened recently there's 10.6 million
job openings so we've reached an
inflection point where there are
significantly more job openings than
applicants and this is a real advantage
to job seekers who now have a bit more
selectivity
in making a decision of what they want
their next job to be
whether it be something that has a
higher salary a better work life balance
maybe the opportunity to work remotely
so we invite uh all those job seekers to
usnews.com to check out not only our
rankings and not only our job profiles
but also uh sub subcategories for
different topics such as business and
healthcare
thank you antonio barbero with a very
cool name you're watching cbs mornings